bring junkies booby fights what in the
world it's movie fights live hashtag
movie fights live welcome to the party
today is a big day I'll get into that in
just a moment but first what up hashtag
all nation hoot-hoot we're miles at um
you guys the championship belt is on the
line today and we have the top contender
and the champion in the house without
any further ado let's meet the
participants the combatants he's one of
the real rejects and he has just
rocketed up to the number one challenger
status I can't believe it
welcome back Greg Alva thanks how I want
to personally thank lon and Billy for
reading all those very complimentary
tweets I was getting before the match
such great support online oh yeah feel
me some more man I think our fans think
the show ends in a murder yeah I don't
think we've ever murdered someone no
yeah there's a lot of like prepare
Greg's funeral now he's gonna get his
car and drive home his traffic is there
some weenie in front of his laptop sink
very sincere note I'm a huge everyone
else I'm a huge big screen junkies fan
movie fights fan I learned the game from
watching Dan so the fact that I don't
know here playing against him is as a
fan is a dream come true and
simultaneously a nightmare at the same
time sad to be here well I mean thank
you for stepping in and just taking our
collective games up here because you've
really added a lot to the festivities
around here so it's awesome to have you
man thanks best of luck to you
and best of luck to the man sitting
across from you he needs no introduction
he is the undisputed movie fights
champion of the world
dan the man Murr
how are you dad great to see you I
usually soften see you over there where
Lana's sitting but right now you are in
a chair you're very comfortable in your
movie fighting chair what does the
champion do to prepare for a title
defense I the same thing I always do
look at the questions I think they're
really good questions take some notes
and just get ready for a good match
that's all you can do how so much of it
is out of my control here's a pitch for
your next title defense or yours
whatever what both competitive so that
the story where the person who learns
from somebody fights them always ends up
with the guy that is the old man winning
right I would love to see a Rocky style
training montage of you guys getting
ready for a movie actually that would
might be kind of boring rocky didn't
train each other that would be weird
yeah true you're not Drago today's
championship title match will be decided
by myself and long Dan calling lon
Harrison Danielle Radford lon you'll be
on the facts today what's going on the
fact zone nothing yet because we haven't
started but no factual inaccuracies thus
far thank you on and I'm on it
to you good sir Danielle Radford please
tell us the capacity that you will be
functioning in today well since movie
fights live is live today I am the voice
of the people I am your conduit I will
be in the chat hanging out there will
also be a poll that is on YouTube that
is the only poll that counts and the
poll answers will go up once all of the
initial arguments have been presented
because it is based on the arguments so
you go there your vote and that winds up
being our tiebreaker if you have any
questions about how that works click the
description down below ask someone in
the chat and we can help you out also I
will be on Twitter
checking the movie fights live hashtag
for any kind of interesting answers
you'll always come up with the best
stuff so get active on the hashtag and I
might shout you out during the show yeah
if you want to make a meme if you wanna
make a dank meme a grimy meme I just a
raw a meme just drop it
yes first day we have a very talented
graphic designer named Kevin yeah Kevin
- Kevin for that thumbnail you guys for
posing topless so Before we jump into
the questions etc once again the first
person to four points wins they're going
to be three regular round questions and
then the top two competitors there are
only two competitors today we'll move
into the speed round so you can be down
three Oh after the first three rounds
and make a furious comeback in the speed
round it'll be anybody's game
without further ado jte dropped that
sick-ass package
[Music]
Thank You Thor yeah Greg cocking his
arms like Henry Cavill fall out okay
here we go question number one of movie
fights who's the best actor or actress
and movies today Wow yeah all right the
best actor or actress working today and
we're gonna start with Greg yeah I'm
gonna be straight to the punch here Tom
Hardy is my pick it might some people
might consider that the obvious choice
then you know like you always hear Tom
Hardy for any new casting announcement
Tom Hardy should be in the role but
there's a reason why cuz the guy can
literally do pretty much anything and
any medium like film or television and
he could switch it up between genres
consistently they can do blockbusters
smaller films he's great in shows like
peaky blinders and he's an actor without
a doubt who consistently embodies his
roles he can change his accent up
countless times and he's like the master
of accents he can morph his body
language so often all the mannerisms and
when he physically changes his body it's
not like oh look Tom Hardy gained some
weight or he bucked up its own support
to amplify his character he can be a
great leading protagonist whether that
he's a hero or an antihero I should just
look at how the whole time when I'm
talking okay you can play a great
villain as seen in the revenant or Dark
Knight Rises often times when he's a
supporting character he steals the
scenes he's in and he can often help
steer a movie that is bad or mediocre
into being recommended simply because of
how amazing his performance is he can
transcend a film it's a strongly
recommended simply due to a powerhouse
performance all right Greg laying the
groundwork for Tom Hardy Dan yeah it's
such a hard question to ask to answer
because you can answer like ten
different things so I was trying to
figure out like my basis was like if I'm
gonna hire one actor to be in a movie
and I know that they're gonna deliver
and I know that they're gonna give a
great performance no matter what the
movie is who is it gonna be and the name
that came to my mind was Emily Blunt
Emily Blunt is
is an actor who has crossed genres she
has held down summer blockbuster action
movies she has held down romantic
comedies just this year we saw her at
the forefront of a children's fantasy
film and a horror film
both of which both performances of which
were hugely critically acclaimed in the
case of Mary Poppins Returns I would say
that her performance is more acclaimed
than the film itself and again the best
is such a hard thing to quantify and so
for me it is looking at everybody who's
working today who's the person that I
can hand the reins to if I'm a director
and say I know they're gonna be great
for the part I know they're gonna be
great for the material I know that
they're gonna bring to the role what's
required of it I know I can put them
against anyone else in this film and not
have to worry about them holding their
own and I know that they're gonna
deliver a fantastic performance and that
for me is Emily Blunt let's fight it out
you two yeah Emily Blunt was actually
when you get the questions for movie
fights you have to submit an option a
and option B she was actually gonna be
my option C and in this scenario simply
because I don't feel I think Emily Blunt
is a great actress and I think she
deserves more opportunities and more
leading woman roles but she simply
hasn't been given enough opportunities
to demonstrate as much range as someone
like Tom Hardy I'm not saying that she
doesn't have the capability she
certainly has the potential but she just
really hasn't been given that
opportunity to do things like that Tom
Hardy does so well where he can really
just morph his body language and his
mannerisms and his accents and whereas
Emily Blunt I feel has the emotional
depth and sometimes she can like change
her voice but overall I feel like where
she really shines is like supporting
roles I think sorry you know that's good
I I disagree I disagree because you know
first of all you know it's not lead
actor it's it's what whatever kind of
party are they gonna work in Emily Blunt
just held her own against Tom Cruise
she's held her own against Miss Piggy
she's hold her own against aliens she's
held their own against kids I mean I I
don't think it's what kind of roles
specifically you're gonna give an actor
I think she's been given some great
opportunities I think
under-recognized for the opportunities
that she's been given but she's just she
was just as great in Sicario as a you
know a DEA agent against MINUSTAH del
toro as she was in a quiet place with
John Krasinski which is a completely
different type of film a completely
different vibe a completely different
feel and tone and she's just as brewing
it in both of those I Tom Hardy you know
I was a PHA I was a fan of venom largely
because of Tom Hardy my problem with Tom
Hardy is first of all I think that he
does one thing really really well and a
lot of different genres which is play
the heavy play the authority play the
guy the intimidating guy as so many of
his roles fall into that bucket not all
but I would say most and secondly the
other thing about me with Tom Hardy is
while I am a fan of his you're right he
does do a lot of things he does change
his voice he does do big accents he goes
big and more often than not when I'm
watching Tom Hardy in a movie I'm not
thinking about how seamlessly he's
blending into the role I'm looking at
the film and going like oh look what Tom
Hardy's doing that's what I thought Jake
venom I didn't think about oh look what
Eddie Brock's doing I'm like well Tom
Hardy's going crazy in this role and I
think sometimes it works to the
detriment I would argue that the Dark
Knight Rises he was a distraction
Bane was a distraction in that movie
because of the choices that Tom Hardy
made because people were making fun of
him from the word go I think sometimes
he goes overboard and he brings in a
weird way sometimes too much to the role
because he wants to go so distinctive
that it comes back around and you're
just watching Tom Hardy do an accent
that's a fair argument but at the end of
the day I really do disagree with that I
think Tom Hardy can play these like
larger-than-life characters like Bane
but Bane what became an iconic character
pretty soon
normally with comic book characters like
that that are so different from the
source material itself it's vastly
different than the source material he
made it his own he had to fall I feel
like that's a very underrated
performance in a lot of ways actually of
how he had to follow up Heath Ledger's
the Joker because for years people were
cosplaying us in four years people
people still do that Bane voice because
it's an iconic voice so even though you
might objectively speaking might not
been a big fan of it or it was
distracted by it it became an iconic
role and I also think he doesn't always
play huge characters
I feel like there's a lot of restrained
performances like in the movie Lockheed
demonstrated something that very few
actors can do lock is just hit the
cameras only on him the entire time yes
there's actors who are coming on the
speakerphone but he's the only actor you
see on screen that's a very restrained
performance and I also think movies like
warrior are a very restrained
performance where you can get like the
tough brooding side of him but it's kind
of hard it's like a Marlon Brando like
performance and but that when he does
the bigger characters I think he really
does shine a hell of a lot it's always
impact I think it's so cool that he can
play the big characters the intimidating
characters and then play the more just
regular guy kind of characters like I
remember what he really came on to the
scene he did Bronson first but then he
did inception following it and for some
reason inception he's just a he's not a
big character in that yet people were
really curious about this dude people
were kya and usually when I see a Tom
Hardy best up list
they usually rank Tom Hardy's work on
there and I also think Tom Hardy's just
got the best eyes in the business
because there's something about like
looking into the soul of an actor
through his eyes he can play these roles
like Mad Max where a lot of his face is
covered a lot of the time or Dunkirk or
even Bane where he don't see his face
just his eyes but you can like feel into
his soul which i think is a rare quality
Emily Blunt I think just had literally I
just don't think she has demonstrated
anywhere near as much range in her
performances and I also think that when
she does leading roles more often than
not she's not that talked about thing of
that movie a quiet place the real star
of that movie that I found to happen was
John Krasinski's filmmaking achievement
or with Sicario I felt everyone was
talking about Benicio del Toro primarily
that someone there was a follow up
everyone was really excited for Benicio
but there's no backlash of the fact that
she wasn't returning for Sicario too I
think when it's a supporting character
she doesn't she does a good job I think
she's a really great actress but she
just similarly hasn't had enough
opportunities to demonstrate anywhere
near as much embodiment and
transformation as much as Tom Hart
suited the transformation acting isn't
just transformation and I disagree about
the quiet place Emily Blunt was the
person that was getting Oscar and Oscar
buzz for her performance in that film
not John Krasinski so much of the film
up to Ana
including the very last shot rested
entirely on Emily Blunt not only her
performance but largely her wordless
performance audio film I think she's
really give you being the only guy on
camera and I I you know I'll put that
right up against not literally not being
able to talk and having to play the
entire film or much the entire film
completely with body language and on
your face those are party doesn't when
madmax though well I'm just saying that
it's not like she has not risen to the
same kinds of challenges which is sort
of what you're saying is that she has
not arisen in the same kind of
challenges that he does I don't think
that's true and then also the fact that
she's not to stand out even in movies
Russia has the lead look at something
like Mary Poppins Returns which just
came out not only was she the standout
in that movie she took on a task that
most people would not have taken on in
the sense that Julie Andrews is Mary
Poppins is one of the very few cinematic
performances that people like that's
untouchable right you can't you cannot
you should even go near it it's stupid
to go near it because you'll never be
that good she went into that role and
made it her own I did the conversation
coming out of Mary Poppins Returns was
not like oh well she's no Julie Andrews
she took that role and she made it her
own which is really hard when you're
working with a role that big that is one
of the biggest challenges so I think
that she has had the opportunity to take
on a big challenge like that and she
succeeded she has had the opportunity to
take on the lead she's that she and Tom
Cruise are the co-leads of edge of
tomorrow sure and she held that movie
just as much as she did I would not say
that she's largely in supporting roles
but even in supporting roles she excels
devil worse product no I really support
I think she's good like Tom Hardy who I
think is good in everything I think
Emily Blunt is good in everything she
does as well I just I think that
everything Emily Blunt has essentially
done in terms of range Tom Hardy has
done that but even more so I have not
seen Tom Hardy dancing with animated
Penguins about the emotional depth of
the performance in the song yeah that's
a challenge that Tom Hardy is said to
it's not this thing's Tom Hardy has done
with in terms of like even movies like
legend where he's playing twins and the
only difference is one has glasses and
slicked back hair but he doesn't he has
this incredible ability to commit so so
much
to both of those characters which is I
don't know how you do homework on those
rolls they're both tough guys warrior
he's a tough guy Mad Max he's a tough
guy bein as a tough guy Locke is a tough
guy Bronson's a tough he's a so many of
his roles are based off of tom hardy
being a tough guy the stoic guy and you
know III don't see as much range there
as I see an Emily point I really don't
and I and I love what he does I just
don't see the dynamics I don't if I'm
gonna cast a rom-com I'm not gonna put
Tom Hardy in the lead because I don't
think that he's gonna be able to carry
you know that further when I was going
through the movie This Means War on the
reviews for that movie which is not a
good movie almost and it's a rom-com and
almost like so many critics were just
going but Tom Hardy's the actual good
part of this movie Tom Hardy's the
actual good part let's shift gears and
move to final thoughts you guys Greg
started softly yeah I just feel like
Emily Blunt simply hasn't demonstrated
as much range intern I feel like she
always has the emotional depth down but
I don't
maybe transformation isn't everything
but it's a major player a major factor
into doing performances she's proven
herself to be a scene-stealing
Supporting Actress consistently but I
personally feel that she's usually out
signed by something or someone else in
her few actual leading roles is Mary
Poppins Returns was the one movie I can
really give to you where it's like
everyone was talking about her but I
don't really think that's a role with a
lot of depth she has the emotional depth
but so does Tom Hardy I don't think Tom
Hardy only plays these like tough guy I
don't think in Locke he's a tough guy
he's a very weak emotionally weak
character in that movie he's not strong
in that movie he switched in and out of
blockbusters indie drama television on a
consistent basis and a much wider
variety to of John Rowe work and in a
much wider variety of roles he has a
reputation for like changing a body
language mannerisms full
three-dimensional transformation on a
consistent basis hopping in and out a
leading man villain supporting
characters who always steal the show and
has always met with praise and he's
shown with movies like Locke you can
carry a whole movie with only him on
screen he's shown a legend he could play
two people in the same movie two
distinct different characters there's
just so much about him where he can be
multi
restrained performances like in the drop
or very out-there characters like
Bronson and it's difficult to find an
actor like this who can hop around
mediums genres and roles like Tom Hardy
usually if he's in the movie he's the
talk of the movie I've seen so many
movies that I've gone from mediocre bad
to recommended Emily Blunt may have the
potential but to put it bluntly
opportunity or enough time to truly
showcase as much that's like she has the
emotional depth but I really feel like
physical transformation mannerisms
accents all that is also that's not
something that should be discredited for
for Tom Hardy's work thanks Greg dan I'm
not discrediting it I just think that
Emily Blunt has done everything and more
because first of all physical
transformation look at double Schwartz
Prada and look at the slab of steel that
she is an edge of tomorrow tell me that
she's not physically transformed she
doesn't bulk up like Bane but she's done
physical transformation the range
argument is weird for me to argue
against for Emily Blunt because if you
look at her body of work tell me where
Tom Hardy is done horror comedy musical
sci-fi action drama animated voices kids
movies to make to say that Emily Blunt
has not had the range that Tom Hardy has
I think that she said an enormous amount
of range and far more genres than Tom
Hardy has demonstrated and secondly I
just think that she has shown the
capability of being able to do more
there are different Tom Hardy plays a
great tune and a lot of his roles are
different riffs on the same thing legend
was a big transformation but again it
was two brothers that were big all tough
guys and that's so many of his roles Tom
Hardy is a great instrument Tom Hardy if
I'm gonna if I'm gonna cymbal an
orchestra and I need a great bassoon I'm
gonna get Tom Hardy but if I want
somebody to come in and play every
instrument in the orchestra I'm bringing
an Emily Blunt because I think she has
had that opportunities and I think every
opportunity she's had to excel and stand
out she has shown that she is more than
capable and that's why she's my pick for
the best actor working today whoo
man what a first round that was but yes
yeah just just two behemoths trading
blows and the center is arrange like
factually what do we have Tom Hardy has
not danced with animated Penguins but I
very much recommend going to YouTube and
just typing in Tom Hardy dancing there's
a number of delightful clips the yo 5
sorry he he does not experience dancing
on an amateur level but not with
animated penguin we have talked a little
bit about how long you know the the sort
of range of these careers the body of
work I thought it was interesting that
emily Blunt's been acting since 2003 Tom
Hardy's debut only two years earlier as
first one was in 2001 so comparable
length careers that was all I had to
fast
yeah man I do not want to make a choice
this is to you guys this collision the
unstoppable force versus an immovable
object for sure like during this very
argument I was like leaning towards one
and then the other pulled me in I mean
just the filmography x' greg you laid
out such like all these distinct movies
like at the end like you drop like the
little gems like the drop and stuff like
that but then dan you make a good point
that is he too much the tough guy and
then you're talking about the all the
varied things that Emily Blunt can do
but the question is who's the best actor
or actress working in movies today these
are all different components the
filmography the range I feel like at the
end of the day I heard the most
specificity and the the just by the
slightest of edges from Greg with the
big roles the smaller roles the tiny
films the major villains everything
added up and then looking into his eyes
I thought Dan made a great argument as
well but Greg just by a hair lon
yeah both fighters did great and I'd
like Greg did a really good job of
defending against the sort of tough-guy
argument as soon as I heard that are
I was like locked in the drop those are
great movies where he's very straight
and he brought up both lock of the drop
I was glad to get that but they said
that I felt like Dan especially in his
final closing argument really sealed the
deal so much of the debate came down to
who had the better range and I think Dan
made a great point that Emily Blunt show
tremendous range it basically every
genre that there is I thought that was a
really compelling argument II made at
the end I'm going with that
it's one one we're going to the internet
to decide Daniel Radford the voice of
the people the voice of the people with
64% of the vote it is Emily Blunt 95% of
the vote goes to Tom Hardy some other
things that the people had other names
that were brought up your Meryl Streep's
or Tom Hanks or Christian Bale mrs.
Davis is you know James McAvoy's I want
to I can't even but y'all go to quarter
pirate all one word on Twitter they are
commenting this match as though it is a
WWE match of the 90s and you'd like
doing Junior and Jerry the King Lawler
ight phille so go make sure that you
check them out in their mentions and
give them some love for that because it
is killing me over here
oh hell yeah good catch there Danielle
thanks for shout in that house all right
it is dan the man one Greg looking to
get on the board here is question 2 of
our championship match
uh here it is of the films actually
nominated what should win Best Picture
this year of the films that have
actually been nominated what should take
Best Picture question to start with
player to Dan it's weird we did a blind
fight on this like three months ago that
we were just like none of us have really
seen any of the nominees and just like
what's gonna win and I jokingly said
aroma cuz that was the one of people
were just like oh yeah Romo is coming
out in a font of Quran there's a lot of
buzz around it and so I kind of made a
flippant argument about it but now
having seen all of them and seeing
what's nominated for the Academy Awards
I'm gonna say Romo for a lot of reasons
first of all I think that when you're
looking at Best Picture it's not even
what's good because I would argue that
most of them someone thinks all of them
are good they're universally
acknowledged dogs in the best picture
race so then it's just it's all
comparison why I think Roma should win
is when the Academy is when you look
who's gonna hold that Best Picture Oscar
for me I think you want to give it to
the movie that best exemplified both the
craft and the impact that filmmaking can
have and that for me was roma both in
the technical achievement that Afonso
Quran and mastery that have founds a
coin show with that film and in the
storytelling and the emotional impact of
that film I think that it is one of
those rare films that is able to both
tell a good story and do it in a very
sneakily innovative way and a very
unique way and I think that of all the
nominees roma stands out is the most
unique as the most innovative and
altogether looking at the entire package
I think it is the most well produced
well crafted an effective film in that
category and that's why I think it
should win thank you Dan and opening
salvo on Roma Greg the stars mourn
people stars born without a doubt this
is my favorite movie of the year because
it hits the mark on everything I'd want
out of a movie
it is superbly directed has amazed
amazing original music in the film that
I think complements the movie and the
performances it enhances the characters
there's gorgeous cinematography it also
got a Oscar nomination for
cinematography as well these fully
realised characters that have just
amazing powerhouse acting in the film
where you get to do insane amounts of
exploration of these two leads and it's
just a wildly moving experience it's
emotional in so many ways I can recall
this film moving me to tears for like 3
to 4 different reasons
throughout the runtime it takes you on
this love journey of a couple that is
just absolutely inspiring at first and
well that's a big movie that explores a
large period of time it's also very
grounded it's very intimate it's very
realistic and in my opinion it's a
better biopic than most actual biopic
movies it takes you on this journey of a
relationship that starts off supportive
that explores when something that starts
off loving and beautiful can turn into
toxic and codependent so many different
theme
of traumas from your past believing
yourself I was moved to tears by so many
things of feeling inspired heartbreaking
struggles the the horrors of addiction
explored in this movie Sam Elliott's
performance it's a wide range of a
captivating musical emotional journey
that for me hits every level of
storytelling and filmmaking on the mark
fight it out y'all I mean I can't deny
that a star was born it's popular with
the Academy was popular with the Academy
this year Israel is popular with the
Academy in 1977 when it was nominated
four times was popular the Academy in
1955 when it got six Oscar nominations
is popular at the academy 1938 when he
got seven Oscar nominations I don't
think that makes the film any weaker
though and I think it's I think it makes
it a retelling of a story that was
already proven popular with Hollywood
that was a familiar story in Hollywood
that was already before it even came out
anointed to be an Oscar frontrunner
because it was a stars born and that
story has reached such iconography
through especially because of the Judy
Garland version and how sure how much
people connect with that that it almost
came in with two or three Oscar
nominations in the bag before the movie
even started Romo on the other hand took
a very unconventional approach it's an
unconventional film it's a is a foreign
language film the number of foreign
language films that have actually been
even nominated for Best Picture is very
small it has had a non-traditional
release it's in black and white it's in
two separate languages it has no
traditional stars it has to stand out
based on its merits and I think that
taking that picture to button taking
that path the best picture is very
important and also why I think it stands
out on the star is more the star is born
for me watching the movie Coast's a lot
on your goodwill for the other versions
of the movie Bradley Cooper's character
is a riff on Chris Christopher
lightning gaga is a riff on the fact
that Barbra Streisand did the role and
the 70s all the story beats are the same
the story beats for this one of the same
as the story beats from the previous
versions you're mixing in some new
actors and some new music which is great
but if I'm looking at what movie am I
gonna award as the best picture of the
year I'm gonna go with the more original
film the personal film the effective
film that didn't have to rely on a
popular story and the story beats from
that story and just plug and play new
things in there that's why I wouldn't
give it to a star is born I feel like
you're really described mean I feel like
The Departed won Best Picture that was a
remake in and of itself and but Bernal
Affairs was not a movie
the Academy knew and was made sure it
was nominated as well and it didn't win
it didn't sure didn't went but it's
still nominated still recognized I think
a star is born what makes it so unique
is its character those characters are
not in the other ones I didn't watch any
of the other stars borns prior to seeing
this one specifically so while there
might be some similar story beats I
think that a star is born has the one
component that one of the main
components and I think a stars where it
hasn't really Trump's over Roma is it's
it's an emotional experience I've seen
your reviews on Roma and I've heard you
say countless times from from your own
videos how youth you feel like it's a
technical achievement but it doesn't hit
you emotionally and I feel like a star
is born is a movie that can I feel like
for a movie it has to be an emotional
experience Roma I've noticed from going
through so many countless reviews the
thing that everyone universally praises
is its technical achievement and its
cinematography the sound editing that
tends to be the thing it seems like the
ones who appreciate it on an emotional
level are the ones who can relate to the
the experience then or if you're someone
who's like read up on why Alfonso korone
crafted this movie but I think it on its
own merits it's not an emotionally
impactful film I found personally for me
I was very I like how you said I was
more of an observer but I wasn't in it I
was I find it that it's I thought it was
a really kind of boring actually I was
very much bored throughout the whole
movie
it doesn't emotionally move me and I
feel like a star is born has a lot more
universal themes that can move an
audience member that I think are
important and I think Roma is limited in
that capacity this is a nice bit of
tricky you tried there but I'm not gonna
fall for it I'm not gonna put my
subjective account of the film and say
that well because Roma didn't move me
then I didn't move anybody and it's not
a lot of people like yes everybody is
moved by films that they were late -
that's how a movies work I would didn't
relate to a star's born why not because
I felt wrote it felt like I've seen this
rise and fall before because not only as
a star is born' been made three times
they've used that pattern in countless
other movies that's what kept me out of
the star is born' and I think that does
transcend more than this
active emotionality of Roma more than
like did it move me personally did it
move some it moved a lot of people
personally stars born moved a lot of
people personally it's not about what's
the most emotionally affecting movie of
the year it's like what movie should win
Best Picture and I think it should be
the movie that is completely crafted
from Alfonzo Kwan one of the best
directors working today a completely
almost a dream a vivid memory of his
calm that came out of his head that was
a construction a completely original
construction the fact that and those
things can be self indulgent the fact
that he came out and he made it
something that was so well put together
and that did affect a lot of people and
it is a very affecting story it's a very
deep story it deals with a lot of big
issues just like a stars born does but
it does it in a way that doesn't riff on
what people have already said and done I
don't want a movie that wins Best
Picture that is a remake of a movie that
people already love that I don't think
that should be recognized I think
originally I think the star is born is
totally what makes the stars born this
version original is the fact that you
have unique characters the characters
are not from yours they are from the
other ones it's the same characters from
their sovereigns Barbra Streisand
versions just because there's something
that's a level of inspiration from it
doesn't mean it's the same I feel I'm
sorry the Roma are very generic bland
characters the last I'm sorry could
boast a fighting man the main character
robot he's one character is one
characters who I could probably count
like 20 minutes of screen time movie the
stars born is about an established star
who has a young Protege who eventually
usurps him and has to deal with the
consequences and the other three
versions were just about an established
pop star who finds a young Protege who
even so you start soon and they have to
do what is emotional it's just really
effective about Romo though on a
universal level I feel like the themes
that are explored in us you're talking
about certain specific plot points I'll
give you that but I think there's so
many different elements of themes in
that movie that are explored that hit
people a university on such a much
deeper level and I think in terms of
craftsmanship Bradley Cooper's
involvement in that film was
exceptionally personal with that movie
he's had his own struggles with
addiction that he had to he had to
become a recovering addict so you can
feel that's why that perform
is so authentic the involvement with the
music in that film well he was him and
Lady Gaga or personally involved in
crafting original scores for that movie
there's no movie out there last year in
2018 that actually really moved me
personally and I feel like Roma is
something that is kind of just a you
have to be a very specific kind of
audience to really enjoy that film what
is that audience that audience are the
people who really look into why Alf I
feel like there's a lot of people when I
hear a lot of reviews they go into that
movie and some of them are just like
yeah I appreciate it technically but
then when they hear Alfonso Kerr owns
meaning and reasoning for it then they
really like it
I think a movie should stand on its own
merits from its own experience I think
watching watching it at home I was very
much bored I think you said you saw it
in the theaters yeah and it was a
fantastic experience in the theater and
I believe in that same review I said you
cannot watch the film landscape of 2018
without seeing Roma because I said
because just because it didn't move me
doesn't mean that you should not
recognize the exceptional craftsmanship
behind that film that's from that same
exact to final thoughts - start with him
and again I think that that's you sort
of help make my point for me which is
that you said when people dig deeper
into the film then they connect to it
and then they understand more about it I
think that's a hallmark of a great film
I think great thumbs should get a bit
better the more that you learned about
them I think that great thumbs should
inspire you to go learn more about where
they came from I don't I didn't hate as
stars born and they're not gonna deny
that it had an emotional impact but I
think when you look at it we look at the
craftsmanship and you're saying what was
the best picture that that was produced
in a year is it the movie that is very
universally accessible that does in my
opinion and I think and very objectively
in some other ways specifically it's an
adapted screenplay that does rely on a
story that's been done many many times
that has goodwill that has an emotional
attachment to a lot of people that they
brought into the movie already or is it
the film that is a wholly original
creation that did affect a lot of people
emotionally and that did inspire a lot
of people to go and learn more about it
learn more about where it comes from and
then appreciate it on a whole new level
that's the kind of movie that I want the
Academy to put its stamp on to say we're
telling you that this is the movie that
you should go out there and see because
you were going to
continue to find new things in this
because it's so deeply crafted and well
constructed I'll you know a star is born
I liked it I know that a lot of other
people liked it
but best picture is the mark of a very
special mark and I think should be mark
of originality of craft and of depth and
those are the things that I think Roma
has more than the stars worth Greg I
have to really have a lease and
sincerely disagree with the fact that
you have to look stuff up in order to
truly appreciate this movie I think a
movie should stand on its own merits
just from that experience I don't feel
like I don't want to have to go what I
did have fonczek or I'll make this oh
now I love this movie I don't want to
have to look these things up in order to
actually appreciate the film I think in
terms of a narrative the characters are
very bland I think it's a I think that's
why I thought it was a very boring film
I wasn't emotionally invested in it you
have to go you have to be a very
specific type of audience to be
emotionally invested in at the end of
the day movies moving pictures are
supposed to be a moving experience and a
star is born as the film that really
moves you I think there's some strong
technical achievements with that film
but it really is the kind of movie for a
specific crowd it's impressive on a
technical scale but not very moving or
has much emotional connective tissue and
there's evidently I think a strong
divide for that purpose I think there's
a big strong divide between people who
are actually emotionally connected and
people just appreciate on a
craftsmanship level I I feel like unless
you have lived within that culture right
up on on pounds of chrome you won't
appreciate that movie as far as a star
is born I feel like that is a movie that
really hits the feels for so many
different purposes
it hits you on the fact of what Lady
Gaga believing in herself that first
moment when she goes up on stage and she
starts singing man it's the creator the
theater crying or the Sam Elliott
relationship the the unresolved tension
between him and Bradley Cooper those
horrors of addiction the idea of
exploring the how relationships can
start off loving and then go into the
toxic and enabling these are the things
that I feel like universally we all can
feel we don't have to look these things
up in order to understand what's going
on and in terms of best picture as well
it's
that's also about art I think the mood
doli a star is born is that so much of
the issues that start occurring with
lady gaga
and bradley cooper are the fact that
lady gaga is not honoring her own
authentic version of art something that
is truly at her heart and in that hey
that rock but in that movie it's so much
about staying true and authentic to who
you are as an artist as well and I feel
like for Best Picture you got to have
that I think it's a technical mastery in
its scope the time the journey
storytelling directing acting editing
cinematography is especially delightful
in that movie the original music
enhances the emotional journey in it
Romo keeps you at a distance whereas
star is born' transports you in there to
a strong emotionally felt character
driven narrative it has to be a mood I
think best picture has to be a movie
that can move a whole audience in a more
Universal way that also has a skill and
craftsmanship and the depth of a worthy
Best Picture time okay
whoo quite a throwdown Mon what do we
got factually I did not really have any
facts to check everything I heard was
clean that they had the amount of
remakes of a star is born right we had
all the names right everything good
the name is Bradley Cooper the name is
Alfonso Cuaron all correct yeah the guy
naked naked martial arts guy lon please
go ahead and give us your thoughts
question this was this was really tough
I felt like both there was a lot of
back-and-forth there was a lot of like
dodge and parry it was hard to sort of
pick one you know person who was sort of
winning it wasn't really back and forth
of me
I felt ultimately like I think Dan spent
a little too much time hitting a stars
born on being a remake and I think Greg
had some pretty good responses to that
like that doesn't necessarily mean
they're not doing new stuff and they are
different timing they have different
names of different sort of backstories
they're different characters even if
they're in similar scenarios so
ultimately I feel like I just heard more
from Greg about why a star is born is
great and deserves recognition so I'm
going with Greg thank you long that is
one vote for Greg yeah on this question
yeah two very different movies and I
felt like you both laid the groundwork I
I feel
you know there are many things there's
there there are movie facts there are
things that we could thrown into our
opinions and then passion and Greg
really started to bring this passion
about his feelings about the film and I
felt that really just started to like he
was so passionate that he got more
specific into his breakdown of a star is
born
whereas I felt like like I heard these
words from Dan like craft and impact but
there was less of an unpacking of the
specifics whereas I felt like Greg was
just unpacking more specifics and for
also some of the reasons that lon
mentioned I also am going with Greg so
Greg you take this Danielle what did the
poll have to say the polls it was 61%
for Roma and 38% for a star is born so
I'm going to hear about that in the chat
hi guys I'll be right in and for
comments or other movies black Klansmen
got a lot of love and the shots a lot of
love for black panther we had some
people pulling for green book and I I
messed this up every time I'm so sorry
it's a why geekness all one word on
Twitter said I think this is interesting
because it shows how there is no real
standout of the eight Oscar nominees
this year they are a there are eight
films and they all have arguments
against why they should win which is
something that I think I mean I try but
there's a few that I would have argued
over any of the other eight credit Terry
bean all right sorry okay so that's more
personal there's some other ones that
have been eighth grade eighth grade was
robbed okay sorry I get passionate about
that um so we're tied up one one two oh
my goodness you guys have come to play
here is question number three sweating
so much
what's the most underappreciated movie
of all time oh that simple question yeah
great hours trying to find an answer for
this one alright so back around Gregg
you'll start us off what is the most
underappreciated movie of all time okay
well I have an odd pic I love when Billy
and JT decided give me their opinions
before a show my pick I was looking at
it I was like what's the film that is
when people watch it people actually go
this is so much better than I thought it
would be and for me there was I had to
go my heart on this one because I
thought I wrote like I'm sure dad did
too I were like 25 movies to hell
and then I found myself just going I
gotta go with my heart it's gonna seem
like an odd choice but I feel like I
have a good defense for it and that's
the movie walk hard the Dewey Cox story
to me it's a it's a spoof comedy of
musical biopics
that drastically underperformed at the
box office and it did not make its money
back it is a big flop but it's without a
doubt one of the best spoof comedies in
that genre of spoof comedy it's one of
the best in that genre and I admire a
well-crafted comedy
I feel like comedies often nowadays it
feels like they usually have like two to
three cameras pointed on actors and they
just let them improv and then they and
then they like let's make a movie out of
this let's edit this together whereas I
feel like well there's some improv to be
had in the movie walk hard you can feel
that there's actually a solid script
behind this and there's some solid
editing behind that movie as well it has
this really underrated performance by
john c reilly who's playing an actual
character there's surprisingly great
original music in the film i feel like
that gets so overlooked there's so much
original music in that film and somehow
this stone just didn't land its audience
yet most people I know that end up
watching it and I'm really loving it and
end up quoting it and I think it's
because of terrible trailers that the
turtle traders made I don't know if you
guys remember it made it look like a
real lowbrow kind of comedy and the fact
that it came out around the time when
there were some terrible spoofs coming
out like scary movie those free brigands
Seltzer films it kind of just got lumped
into that category when it deserves so
much more than that because it's not
just a vignette
of terrible sketch parodies it's an
actual film that's spelling a story
while and be more than just a spoof it's
also a deconstruction of the musical
biopic genre thank you Dan
I look back a little bit further how I'm
gonna get into so many specifics here
last night I'm like Greg III there are
so many different movies that I just was
trying to figure out and you know I
thought about Seven Samurai but I was
like does this influence so much but
then Seven Samurai its art it's it's
it's very acknowledged as being great
then it becomes a semantic thing about
what people say it's great so the one
that I actually went to is one of my
favorites it is a movie called wait
until dark starring Audrey Hepburn Alan
Arkin isn't it as well basically it is
Audrey Hepburn plays a blind woman who's
alone in the apartment she ends up with
a doll full of drugs that these two
these two heavies come to get one of
them is Alan Arkin who's amazing and
menacing and incredible in this movie
and it basically becomes this home
invasion horror movie and so much it
influenced so much of what would come
later and yet is so unrecognized by so
many people I would I would wager that
most people haven't even heard of wait
until dark and yet it it did so many
things that that the horror genre would
picked up ten years later when people
talk about the you know the the the the
the the final girl
against the killer they talk about
Halloween they'll talk about you know
sometimes black Christmas you know
they'll go back to the early slasher
films not many people talk about wait
until dark which was a one-on-one
showdown between Archie Hepburn and a
killer in her apartment people talk
about you know the great jump scares
they'll go back as far as maybe jaws or
they'll go up to cat people I'm like a
film film technical level very few
people talk about the jump scare and
wait until dark with Alan Arkin jumping
out which was one of the best jump
scares at cinema history not usually
cited when people talk about great
moments in horror films even amongst
Audrey Hepburn fans and people talk
about Audrey Hepburn they talk about
Roman Holiday and it's
about breakfast at tiffany's they talk
about all these other movies not many
people talk about wait until dark which
is one of her best performances Silence
of the Lambs is so heralded for you know
the clarice starling exposed to this in
scene with her and a buffalo bill down
in the basement that's wait until dark
that's the end of wait until dark
there's so many bits and pieces of this
movie that would inspire directors and
that would become part of the landscape
that influence things later on that I
think trace heavily back to wait until
dark and yet this is not a movie that is
cited in the genre or as a hugely
influential film what I think it really
was and underappreciated I mean to help
sort of to be part of the opening
movement of so many things that persist
today and to not be cited as one of the
the first films to do it except you know
if you give you Google three articles
deep into most undervalued or most
underappreciated or ten horror movies
you may never have heard of wait until
duck doesn't belong there it belongs up
there with the big boys and that's why I
picked it for the most underappreciated
movie we got two big boys right here
fight it out big boys it's gonna be a
weird argument since we both like our
movies well I had I watched wait until
dark last night for the first time you
could rent it on YouTube guys in case
you guys didn't know so I watched it
last night and while I was doing
research on it I didn't find that I
didn't personally I wasn't going this is
an underappreciated movie if the year it
came out it was one of the most
financially successful films that year
it had its heyday it received Golden
Globe nominations it received an Oscar
nomination for Audrey Hepburn I'll give
you that it's definitely faded in
popularity for sure like no one talks
about it in this year last year no no
but III was looking at some stuff and in
2001 36 years after it was released
this is decades later it was honored by
putting on I want to make sure I get it
right afi's 100 years100 thrills list
and then a what number I don't know
exactly what number but it's on the list
though
and it's decades later there's been a
lot of films I came out with a 36 year
period in that genre and in 2004
relate ranked at number 50 or something
like that you can fact check the summer
their 100 scariest climaxes of all time
so I feel like this is decades later
that it's been the after it came out and
it's so to be a box-office success to
have all the appreciation in its day I
don't feel like it's underappreciated I
feel like it's over look should I mean I
feel like it's uh faded in popularity
whereas walk hard is a film that never
had its do all right I want to talk
about this because I tried to try a
little experiment because in my review
for Bohemian Rhapsody yeah I cited walk
hard and I said this movie without rami
malek would be walk hard like that to me
was the picture of the of the surface
music biopic and so I gue I just googled
walk hard Bohemian Rhapsody I got
through four pages of reviews
referencing walk hard walk hard walk
hard it reminds me walk hard it's like
walk are the Dewey Cox story it's rocky
I mean so many people in their analysis
of Bohemian Rhapsody specifically went
to walk hard and cited it as the the
picture of the the ultimate parody of
this music biopic I think that it is
it's like office space yes it didn't do
well at the box office and it didn't
make its money back but it has grown in
popularity every year since to the point
that it's now cited as as the key parody
of a certain type of film genre it's not
like it's like Austin Powers it's like
office space movies that didn't make a
lot of money but found their voice on
home video everyone that I know it's
seen walk hard people talk about how
funny it is it didn't get lumped in with
epic movie and stuff it's part of the
Judd Apatow assad's it got lumped in
with those movies which is considered a
really good part for comedies one of the
movies that helped jumpstart the comedy
scene from those yeah maybe over time
some people have started to pick up on
it
mm-hmm but I I don't feel like that's a
honestly adding against me the fact that
when you watch Bohemian Rhapsody that
you were like this is walk hard I feel
like if walk hard was more popular
Bohemian Rhapsody wouldn't have been the
film that we got I think so it felt like
so evident like did these filmmakers not
watch that and I feel like that a the
fact that Bohemian Rhapsody is a film
that came out 11 it was like 2007 Walker
came out 11 years after walk hard
shows how great this phone could be at
with with aging but this is the mode
this what I mean though this is the most
underrated movie of all time but it was
flung over 20 years after though but
walk hard is it's gaining in popularity
of all time and I would argue that like
if it's getting more popular
I've Google searches that's where you're
going off no no not off of reading
reviews from outlets dozens of them that
know the movie that know the language of
the movie that know what it's about can
relate it to a current day release that
shows to me that the movie is gaining in
popularity over time which is what
happens right as you're right wait until
dark what's a popular movie in its day
but it's not a movie it has faded over
time and I don't think that it should
have not just because it's a good movie
but because it has so many hallmarks in
the genre particularly in the horror
genre that later films like Halloween
would be celebrated for as the
progenitors of as the originators of as
one of the first to do this but just
because it was our first does that mean
it was better okay I'm trying I'm trying
to make sure we don't get caught in this
too much of a semantics argument okay
but I mean I feel like we just kind of
have to everybody stop the question
though because where's someone you're
seeing under appreciate I got to bring
it back to the fact that your film was
financially successful and the fact that
it had Oscar nomination the fact that
decades later it was being put on like
like best of list prestige a list of all
the AFI does 15 they did a list a year
and then everyone was getting they ran
out of things to do and they would get
so specific that it's not surprising
that wait until dark would pop up and
one of those lists I don't even know
what number I watched that Bravo thing
it was like a Halloween like multi-part
special that had like a hundred
different movie moments on it and again
wait until dark was one of them but what
do you say it was like number what
number was it but 50 or 50 or something
here's here Greg final thoughts please I
think walk hard that movie was actually
a financial disaster that was much
smarter than the marketing for the film
will have led you to believe there is a
wildly underrated performance by john c
reilly there's underrated performances
by Kristen Wiig jenna fischer and their
hilarious cameos is in its
it's one of those great spoof comedies
that is also a deconstruction of a John
rrah
it's it's something that is actually not
recognized it's just not recognized for
how brilliant of a film it is how super
insanely witty and smart and at the fact
that it's a comedy
that's a spoof movie but they managed to
put in like hilarious original music in
there or have hilarious montages in
there I feel like people who watch it
start quoting it but it never got the
prestige recognition and never didn't
make the money it just it's the fact the
matter is it's so much more
underappreciated than wait until dark is
a wait until dark was appreciated in its
time and maybe in 2019 no one is talking
about it but that doesn't mean it's not
recognized for its quality it was a
financial success received it Award
nominations in nearly forty years later
it's being put on prestige lists so
clearly had a good time span at the
break 100 greatest scare moments is not
a prestigious list I would argue well
it's the best of lists being recognized
okay it's just been over 50 years it's
been over 50 years
so it's faded in popularity just like
now there's so many films from the 60s
that were amazing that have faded in
popularity and I wouldn't say and I
watched wait until dartle and I know
this is very subjective but the fact
that it was a financial success received
nominations and is not ever really
considered to be in the top 10 best I
don't think it's one of the best of its
genre that's just my personal opinion
but I feel like if it was one of the
best of its genre it would be put up
there with the works of like Alfred
Hitchcock films like psycho or
rear-window or vertigo or reference in
this lump sum that you're talking about
I think there's a reason why it was kind
of forgotten about is because it's not
one of the best of his genre whereas
walk hard is one of the best of its
genre and I think it's being recognized
for that right now
walk hard is getting more popular as
time goes on that happens to comedies
all the time just because it wasn't a
success when it came out doesn't mean
that it's underappreciated
it's it's being appreciated more and
more as each year goes by wait until
dark again it's not about popularity at
its time I think that helps make the
point it was a popular film at its time
so popular in fact that it went on to
influence other films but now has been
forgotten as part of the fabric of the
genres
and the different conventions in film
that it created that it inspired like I
said even amongst RG Hepburn uh what
she's remembered for wait until dark is
not one of the iconic films when in fact
it was something she got an Academy
Award for and that should be appreciated
I think the fact that it got so much
procedure when it came out and now is a
film that isn't remembered by many
people I think that is a mark of an
underappreciated film it's not just that
it was a good film that people have
forgotten about that happens a lot I
think it was that it was part of a genre
the horror genre at that time that was
mostly Vincent Price movies it was one
of the films that helped birth the
modern horror genre and it is not
remembered as one of those films being a
mom being one moment on Bravo's ten
scariest moments list does that mean it
has a legacy appearing on one AFI list
is that does that mean it has a legacy
it should be on a lot of AFI list it
should be one of those films that is
counted up there with Halloween and
psycho in the suspense onra and it's not
and it's not just because it's good it's
because it has things that other films
would later do that they are celebrated
for like Silence of the Lambs like
Halloween that wait until dark is not
celebrated for it that means that the
film is underappreciated to me time Wow
so let's define matters yes
great stuff fellas lon where we at with
the facts so we mentioned that walk card
was released around the same time as
some other parody films that is true
while card was released in 2007 that's
the same year that epic movie came out
and the following year both disaster
movie and superhero movie were released
so this was the it was the height of the
horrible boost post parody movement we
also mentioned some lists wait until
dark is it appears on bfi's top 10
Audrey Hepburn films it appears it's
number 55 on afi's 100 thrills hundred
years list and it's number 10 on Bravo's
list of the hundred scariest movie
moments one more thing about wait until
dark that I think is interesting comes
from director Terrence Young who also
directed the first two James Bond films
doctor no and From Russia With Love and
he also later did Thunderball that is
true come on man
you on you came through with some
serious facts for their facts lon with
the facts yeah so it's just another
close race here yeah Greg you you really
uh like won me over for like just I need
to check out walk hard again and it is
under appreciated you made an amazing
case as far as the question of uh most
of all time
I thought the points that you brought up
as far as Dan's film being on those
lists only help Dan because it's like oh
this film should be recognized it is
recognized but it's only on these
specific niche lists whereas it's not
like those are like the biggest thrill
like biggest jump scare whatever it was
um yeah I felt like it said okay there's
some appreciate but it debt and Dan
point-by-point went through these are
elements that affected films that
followed it so it's like oh he probably
has a point and if it is that
influential how come I've never seen
this film how come it's not as popular
as like a psycho of vertigo thrillers
that you mentioned from that era so I
felt Dan really laid the groundwork and
yeah my point goes to Dan one I gotta
say I love walk hard one of my favorite
reads the coyotes and it really does I
think the impact of walk hard is real
like musical biopics can't just do the
formula thing or immediately audiences
are like oh it's just like walk cards
like it actually had an impact on its
genre which i think is very significant
having said that I thought Dan just made
a really expert case as to why wait
until dark belongs in the pantheon of
great horror movies and yet is
consistently sort of left out of that
list and it's sort of unacknowledged as
an early landmark horror film ultimately
I have to give the point of that boom
Dan gets the point Danielle what did the
poll have to say 68 percent all right
refreshing so we get fresh numbers you
know it was actually closer so wait
until Derek got 55% with walk hard at
44% other movies that people brought up
Starship Troopers I saw
of someone said mr. nobody which is a
movie I have not heard of so it's got to
be one of those I'm Scott Pilgrim got
some love
a few either without a clue which I
guess is a Sherlock Holmes story with
Ben Kingsley and Michael Caine um and
that sounds great everyone is loving
this fight by the way they keep talking
about how it's just PhD research right
which makes me happy it paid like a
doctor then I mean here was one one
great one from current Kor yn an
underscore W on Twitter who says hunt
for the Wilderland I feel this New
Zealand film flew under the radar here
and never got the attention it deserved
an odd couple adventure that equally
balances hilarious and heartwarming
comedy and hard way Sam Neill Julianne
Denison YTD yeah yeah Wow so after three
questions Dan is up two to one and let's
venture to the speed round shall we yeah
I am so happy I've got to think about my
whole life before you
real quick on speed round works I'll
throw the question out there they'll
just shout out their answers the first
person I hear will get to elaborate on
their answer first it goes 20 seconds 20
seconds and then back around for 10
second rebuttal
10 second rebuttal and that's how that
works
it's 2 to 1 in favor of damn y'all ready
for this yes sir let's do it
thank you great question one of oh end
one more one more thing Danielle will be
chiming in with her own thoughts and
opinions concerning no time for a poll
on the speed round ain't no time propose
the speed round so now I am I still love
y'all I am just not of you now I'm just
a Danielle
no more Borg but talk your talk talk
your [ __ ] make your comments and
everything yeah oh we want that all
right question one here we go who had
the better 2018 debut feature Bo Burnham
was eighth grade or Boots Riley with
sorry to bother you hoots Riley oh yeah
okay we have boots Riley from Dan
we have Bo Burnham from Greg Dan we
heard you first 20 seconds begin as soon
as you begin sorry to bother you with
such a breath of breath of fresh air and
such a risk for a first-time director to
have the guts to make a film like sorry
to bother you and the fact that he
pulled it off the amount of satire
happening in that film on so many levels
on a social level on an economic level
on a pop-culture level he was able to
bring that all together into a weird
crazy abstract masterpiece that I think
is completely individual and one of the
most unique films all right Greg
ah sorry eighth grade was a film that I
recently watched and I was just floored
by it because of the fact of how it felt
insanely authentic yeah sorry to bother
you does have a lot of it's weird
zaniness about it but I really think
that it's not really for everyone I feel
like you get to a point where it's just
a little too much you really have to
suspend your disbelief way too far
whereas eighth grade is something
everyone can really relate to and I
think that's what puts us everybody go
the top for me is you can relate to
eighth grade easily whereas boots Riley
was playing big with a huge risk that's
a great mark for a first-time director
and he pulled it off of relatability is
great I think sorry to bother you is
risky but I also think that it's more
about its ideas and less about its
characters when I would rather watch a
film that's really about it's characters
that mean put on that journey through
there it was kind of like a comedy with
a lot of all these like dramatic horror
elements in there oh man good stuff you
guys Wow Danielle Radford what do you
got oh um you know so I mean I guess
it's basically a fight of is it about
someone who takes a big swing and hits
their first time out or is it about
something that is ultimately more
relatable I will say that both of those
are both of those are great but I feel
like I feel like Gregg did a really good
job at hitting back on on some of the
points about sorry to bother you so I'm
gonna go with Gregg on this one Thank
You Danielle I shouted out my love of
eighth grade earlier but um in this case
I felt like Dan just got really into
some of the just the the fabric of sorry
to bother you that it was a huge risk
the social commentary and like which you
simplify by calling it like weird
zaniness I felt like that was a way
oversimplification of so much that was
going on in this movie and Dan really
sold me of just like he took that huge
swing and he accomplished like that
voice was clear and heard even though I
prefer eighth grade I thought Dan just
zeroed in on that so I'm going with Dan
on that
my favorite movies of the year I like
both of these arguments - yeah there's a
lot going on this rat ultimately I felt
like Greg in his in his final argument
kind of help dad a little bit he was
saying how many different things sorry
to bother you was accomplishing and how
many different things he was doing and
how sort of big and wild it was and I
think those are points in sorry to
bother you saver and backed up sort of
what they was saying about how bold and
original and brave it was so I'm going
with that boom that is one for Dan C
sorry to bother you I think both of
these are top 10 2018 we absolutely see
those movies it is 3:1 dan this is
actually game points so Greg you need
this money for going yeah
all right game point for Dan here we go
question number two the speed around
best Spike Lee movie do the right thing
well I'm not too familiar with Spike
Lee's filmography I guess I will argue
black clansmen okay I'm not familiar
with filmography that much we have black
Klansmen from Craig
we heard Dan would do the right thing
first 20 seconds begin when you speak
Spike Lee has always been a provocative
filmmaker and I think the problem with
provocative filmmakers is a lot of times
they're from still to of the moment and
to dated as time goes on do the right
thing as a movie that was made about 30
years ago that is more relevant today
than it was then because Spike Lee was
able to capture that moment but in such
a universal way as far as race relations
as far as just human relations human
beings relating to each other that it
the reason I love black clansmen so much
was because it was a movie that managed
to have so much social commentary about
things that occurred in the past but of
how they also linked back to today it
was a movie that I would consider but
the second best movie of the year simply
because of the fact that that when it
has that tire out at the end of what's
going on in monitoring times it haunted
me and horrified me I had to start doing
research on it it really impacted me
because of oh but I think that's what
sets it apart is that black clansmen is
so specifically tied to the moment right
now with Charlottesville whereas do the
right thing
operated on such a great level on a
broader level that it remains relevant
without having to get to specifics I
think it's actually more powerful the
fact that it's about today because of
the fact that it's actually not the
movie doesn't take place in today it
takes place years ago showing that times
haven't really changed that much I think
that's a compliment to the power of the
filmmaking oh boy ah good stuff you guys
let's go too long oh I gotta go first
definitely two spikes best movies book
great arguments ultimately I felt like I
felt like Dan kind of kind of got Greg
on the you know do the right thing has a
timeless quality it's just as relevant
or more today whereas black clansmen so
specifically tied to this moment
especially as Greg mentioned that
amazing sort of final montage so they
just barely it's a slight advantage but
I would give this one to Dan that's one
for Dan Daniel Radford would you favor
us with your thoughts I have to agree I
thought that it was a great argument
when you talk about what the difference
between something that is so much about
something happening right now and about
this moment versus something that is
timeless and that is successful me
personally I wouldn't pick school days
but apparently since neither what have
you decided it was important enough i'm
clockers to Dan you are so sure the
movie fights champion thank you very
much I know
the last fun is the hardest but I cannot
think of anyone that made me work harder
for than Gregg I'm serious like thanks
I've like 100% series dude like you
killed it
so thank you thank you for a great fight
yeah I have the easy job over here but
it was super freakin hard because like
listening to both of your breakdowns
like I was the very unenviable position
right here having to pick those two cuz
you were both so damn good uh Dan uh
thoughts feelings out outs that I love
this game
yeah this game I love this fight
specifically I I think I say that every
time I fight that I love this fight
specifically but I really like these
last several fights because you know in
the last a little bit just because it's
been great to just come on and have a
great debate have disagreements and just
hash it out in a fun way and in a way
where you know it's just a great
conversation and a great debate that's
what I love doing so this has been a
this is really fun for me and thank you
Greg for a great thank you
hell yeah I feel like yeah I mean just
it is like PhD film school stuff like
like you you guys and there's passion
because like we're all fans here it was
so much fun to just be this close to the
action Greg I mean well played good sir
well wait thanks yeah
I first off before I thank everyone here
at screen jockeys I want to thank my
girlfriend Olivia and my best friend
John for putting up with my anxiety
leading up to this fight that was not I
mean the the idea I am such a big fan of
damn Merle specifically like I have to
like I always say screams but I've
watched I do watch charting with Dan and
I do watch screen junkies news every
single day hello everyone five days a
week it's on and so the idea of Dan
disagreeing with me for an hour
are you was like oh my god that's kind
of terrible yeah that's really like work
past that psychologically throughout
this game and no it's just an absolute
honor to be here I started off as a fan
of the show and and now that I the fact
that I got the opportunity to be up here
with you I've never done anything with
Dan so it was fun yeah this one's
fighting someone for the first time too
though like it's just a little fight
like Spencer and Joe Lee how much fun to
fight somebody remember five before it's
like it's it's like it's like improv I
know the Proms like but I imagine it's
what it promised like know like where
they're gonna come at you or where their
sneak attack might be yeah yeah for sure
but yeah you really came in and held
your own and man you made it every
choice was difficult
please tell us uh tell everybody where
they can find the real rejects people
real rejects go watch my Avengers
in-game sketch I put a lot of hard work
into that thing channel trailer I feel
like you're right away and Greg Alba on
Instagram Twitter that be maybe
amazeballs
hey yes thanks Greg and I imagine like
coming in to face Dan 101 movie fight is
like oh I have to face the Undertaker at
WrestleMania
awesome work long please say say hi to
everybody and tell them something
special hi everybody follow me on
Twitter at L ons and I'm doing a podcast
about Game of Thrones for the new final
season along with Ken knapsack and some
other great people cast early talk find
it wherever you listen great pun Thank
You lon
Daniel Radford thank you for being the
social media hostess with the mostess
well thank y'all so much and I will say
thank you on behalf of the rest of my
people in the chat my chat people yeah
I'm Greg you are getting so much love in
the chat and on really people are there
that's amazing we're accusing us of
rigging it in Dan's favor that's how
that's how I really work that's how I
might overlap the speedrun I was like
you know I think it's so great that
you're always like I'm such a fan but
you're also like you're a peer bro you
know that's right it's upside be in
rigging movie fights is there mr. Vegas
know about should I be getting a piece
of the action on this show all sponsors
have they want they want to consist a
champion so you know you got a young
brand's happy like if I have to sit here
I like judge like a rigged match that
would be just boring junk
yeah but yes so uh final thoughts you
every one of the chats really happy find
me all over and also JK Simmons y'all
happy why would that I don't play it's
the chat you know they've been
counterpart everybody very undervalued
show right on Danielle always given the
people what they want and thank you for
watching this championship match
appreciate you please come back again
next week and follow me on Twitter
Instagram at Hal Rudnick and gotta say
thanks again to our nation whoo-hoo
Perceval in the house see you next time
everybody
oh and thank you JD and Billy biz
[Music]
you